Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I am a light transport researcher by trade,
and due to popular request, today I am delighted
to show you these beautiful results from a
research paper.
This is a new light simulation technique that
can create an image like this.
This looks almost exactly like reality.
It can also make an image like this.
And, have a look at this - this is a virtual
object that glitters.
Oh my goodness.
Absolutely beautiful.
Right?
Well, believe it or not, this third result
is wrong.
Now, you see, it is not so bad, but there
is a flaw in it somewhere.
By the end of this video, you will know exactly
where and what is wrong.
So, light transport eh?
How do these techniques work anyway?
We can create such an image by simulating
the path of millions and millions of light
rays.
And initially, this image will look noisy,
and as we add more and more rays, this image
will slowly clean up over time.
If we don’t have a well-optimized program,
this can take from hours to days to compute
for difficult scenes.
For instance, this difficult scene took us
several weeks to compute.
Okay, so what makes a scene difficult?
Typically, caustics and specular light transport.
What does that mean?
Look!
Here we have a caustic pattern that takes
many-many millions, if not billions of light
rays to compute properly.
This can get tricky because these are light
paths that we are very unlikely to hit with
randomly generated light rays.
So, how do we solve this problem?
Well, one way of doing it is not trusting
random light rays, but systematically finding
these caustic light paths and computing them.
This fantastic paper does exactly that, so
let’s look at one of those classic closeups
that are the hallmark of any modern light
transport paper.
Let’s see.
Yes.
On this scene, you see beautiful caustic patterns
under these glossy metallic objects.
Let’s see what a simple, random algorithm
can do with this with an allowance of two
minutes of rendering time.
Well, do you see any caustics here?
Do you see these bright points?
These are the first signs of the algorithm
finding small point samples of the caustic
pattern, but that’s about it.
It would take at the very least several days
for this algorithm to compute the entirety
of it.
This is what the fully rendered reference
image looks like.
This is the one that takes forever to compute.
Quite different, right?
So let’s allocate 2 minutes of our time
for the new method and see how well it does.
Which one will it be closer to?
Can it beat the naive algorithm?
Now, hold on to your papers, and let’s see
together.
What?
On this part, it looks almost exactly the
same as the reference.
This is insanity!
A converged caustic region in two minutes!
Whoa.
The green closeup is also nearly completely
done.
Now, not everything is sunshine and rainbows,
look, the blue closeup is still a bit behind,
but it still beats the naive algorithm handily.
That is quite something.
And yes, it can also render these beautiful
underwater caustics as well in as little as
5 minutes.
5 minutes!
And I would not be surprised if many people
would think this is an actual photograph from
the real world.
Loving it.
Now, what about the glittery origami scene
from the start of the video?
This one.
Was that footage really wrong?
Yes it was!
Why?
Well, look here!
These glittery patterns are unstable.
The effect especially pronounced around here.
This arises from the fact that the technique
does not take into consideration the curvature
of this object correctly when computing the
image.
Let’s look at the corrected version, and,
oh my goodness.
No unnecessary flickering anywhere to be seen,
just the beautiful glitter slowly changing
as we rotate the object around.
I could stare at this all day.
Now, note that these kinds of glints are much
more practical than most people would think.
For instance, it also has a really pronounced
effect when rendering a vinyl record and many
other materials as well.
So, from now on, we can render photorealistic
images of difficult scenes with caustics and
glitter, not in a matter of days, but in a
matter of minutes.
What a time to be alive!
And when watching all these beautiful results,
you are thinking that this light transport
thing is pretty cool, and you would like to
learn more about it, I held a Master-level
course on this topic at the Technical University
of Vienna.
Since I was always teaching it to a handful
of motivated students, I thought that the
teachings shouldn’t only be available for
the privileged few who can afford a college
education, but the teachings should be available
for everyone.
Free education for everyone, that’s what
I want.
So, the course is available free of charge
for everyone, no strings attached, so make
sure to click the link in the video description
to get started.
We write a full light simulation program from
scratch there, and learn about physics, the
world around us, and more.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!